I offer you a glimpse of a legendary
creature lost in time neither ate nor
man but a giant he's had many neighbors
actually I go by Susan Susan yeah Susan
that is a girl's name yes that's correct
it suits you I need someone who knows
the wild places of the world and you're
the world's greatest adventurer
do you ask of me I'm lonely I'm the last
of my kind
but on the other side of the world they
talk of this creature the Yeti
I think these yetis are my cousins can
you take me there I give you my word
okay what is it what your word it's a
figure of speech sounds good what is it
well I'm on my way we have a long way to
go you'll need a map right get Harvey
Bravo thank you now to find the place
you belong you'll need to keep a low
profile
[Music]
oh boy that is gonna let in an awful
draft so let me see if I understand you
plan to travel around the world to the
home of the Yeti I know the secret ways
through the mountains you seek gum
whatever you do do not mention touch no
chicken got it simple hmm greetings
venerable Gamu it is an honor what's
with the chicken it will not be easy but
we will find it your place
Shango MA we call it
what does it mean keep out we hate you
from the other the pits I think you
might be a little too heavy nonsense now
give it all you've got
oh it's hard to know whose fault that
was let's do it again
[Music]